pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
on
roi d'espagne se nomme alphonse bonne
gorden baronne de gros tonnes d'or et
côte de tolède lieutenant-colonel aux
gardes
voilà
[Musique]
pendant ce temps
dans son oratoire alphonse van beurden
retenu à grenade s'incline devant cet
insigne honneur
mais cet honneur ne lui fait pas oublier
son rendez vous
et une
où
il
[Musique]
bah
à
alan garcia
je ne veux pas qu'il soit dit qu'elles
vont recevoir bordeaux n'ait pu prendre
du retard une fois dans sa vie
quelles que soient les circonstances
ouais
[Musique]
je déclare luis garcia vaincu car bien
qu'ayant blessé sur l'adversaire
son jeu était moins élégant dans
l'ensemble or il était convenu que seule
la manière de mener l'assaut des signes
récents vainqueurs
je refuse cet arbitrage vous aviez
demandé cet arbitrage sur ma renommée
parce qu'ils ne se fait pas de duel ni à
madrid ni à grenade
sans que l'on me demande de l'arbitré
dans mon livre qui est parfaitement
exact on ne mentionne aucun refus de cet
arbitrage
vous êtes en droit de le refuser mais je
dois vous demander immédiatement raisons
de ce refus
je crois que seule la mort peut arbitrer
ce combat
puissions nous faire vite monsieur cette
personne que je n'ai ni tué ni blessé en
duel au cours de ces quinze dernières
années qui sont mes invités attendent en
ce moment chez moi célébrer mes noces
avec urac de gommer rays fille de l'oeil
d'or de grenade et du sang des anciens
rois de ce pays si je ne vous tue point
je serai ravi de vous savoir parmi les
invités à la célébration de mes
funérailles
si je vous tue je célèbre mes noces
comme prévu en garde monsieur je vous
prie
allons messieurs nous attend
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur des halles alcon monsieur de
hissage monsieur le duc del soto votre
altesse donc perdre et à la route
monsieur le marquis de los feliz
monsieur le duc de suna monsieur de
castres mes chers frères da je vous ai
choisis vous êtes et 12 hommes de madrid
qui ont eu le plus de duels
vous savez assez combien de fois j'ai
mis votre conscience en repos dans le
cas où l'honneur semblait être compromis
aujourd'hui je suis obligé moi même de
me rapporter à vos lumières parce que je
crains que mon propre jugement soit en
défaut plutôt parce que je crains qu'il
ne soit obscurci par quelques sentiments
de partialité
voici la lettre comme écrivent les
magistrats de bouillon dans le
témoignage est respectable bien qu'ils
ne soient pas des gentilshommes il
m'annonce que mon frère est mort et que
n'ayant pas d'enfant son fief des
ardennes mai tai chi dites moi s'il aux
normes obligent habité le château de mes
pairs ou bien si je dois continuer à
servir le roi dans philippe qui me
comble est bien fait je laisse cette
lettre sur la table et je me retire
je reviendrai dans une demi-heure savoir
ce que vous avez décidé
une demi heure plus tard alphonse van
beurden se présentent aux voix il s'en
trouve 5 pour rester au service 7 pour
aller vivre dans les ardennes
chers amis cette journée qui devait être
une journée de bonheur sera une journée
d'adieux 1 s'il avait voulu dieu et vous
jeu 15 amené avec moi de représentants
de l'espagne partis alliés rose est le
meilleur prévaut de salles qu'il y est
un madrier à grenade consenti voix me
suis pour vivre désormais dans les
ardennes et devenir le maître d'armes ce
fils qui ne manquera pas de me venir
je vous suivrez
l'autre choix vous appartient igo vélez
vous êtes théologien graduée vous êtes
mono monnier acceptez vous de nous
suivre pour instruire dans la religion
catholique et la langue castillane le
fils qui ne manquera pas de nous venir
on
ah ah
monsieur le maréchal permettez moi de me
présenter
marquis d'urfé j'ai entendu dire que
vous êtes l'un des hommes les plus en
vue à la cour de france mais
permettez-moi de vous entretenir en
privé quelques instants mais
certainement sinon cavaliers votre chez
a devancé mon carrosse pour arriver
avant moi à la poste
ce procédé qui en lui même les points
une insulte a pourtant quelque chose de
désobligeant dont je crois devoir vous
demandez raison puis cela naturel ma
chaise et en plus légère que votre
carrosse il n'y a rien là de naturel et
quelle que soit la raison votre chaise à
devancer mon carrosse une faute a été
commise et de l'été par les postillons
je n'ai aucune part dans ce dépassement
c'est un cavalier je ne prétends pas non
plus faire de ceux ci la sphère grave je
vais me contenter du premier sont
attendues encore un instant il me semble
que ce ne sont pas mes postillons qui
ont devancé les vôtres mais que ce sont
les vôtres qui a lentement sont restés
en arrière c'est un cavalier je crois
que vous avez raison
et si vous monsieur fait cette
observation un peu plus tôt avant que
juste tirer mon épée je ne crois pas que
nous nous serions battus mais vous
sentez bien qu'au point où sont les
choses il faut un peu de sang
bravo monsieur monsieur dur fait je suis
désolé pour la peine que je vous ai
donné ouest la guerre vous a valu tant
de blessures qu'un nouveau coup de
guerre que portait sur dans cette
cicatrice
hormats quelle chance le coup porté par
le colonel la mise à jour une balle que
nous n'avions pu extraire l'an dernier
ça va être un jeu d'enfant
et voilà puis je vous offrir mes
services je dois repartir immédiatement
pour paris je désire pour mon fils en
parle un français puisque son destin
d'être élevés en france
acceptez-vous d'être le parrain du
garçon qui doit me venir je lui
souhaiterai l'habileté de son parrain
c'est un grand honneur pour moi je lui
souhaite le courage de son père
[Musique]
m
[Rires]
cela me rappelle le siège de noël nous
avons patauger trois semaines les jambes
dans l'eau cependant notre premier soin
doit être de place est à sec tu le lis
de mon épouse ainsi fut fait l'âtre de
la cheminée légèrement surélevé fut
choisi pour y placer le lier rapporté
d'espagne
et neuf mois après jour pour jour le
fils qui ne pouvait manquer d'arriver
arrive
seigneur alphonse pendent borden je vous
présente alphonse pong borden et gaubert
est ce votre fils
la vie de cet enfant alphonse van borden
icom erez se rallier à la constellation
des gémeaux et son éducation commence
ouais t'as trois ans le jeune alphonse
tient déjà un petit fleuret à 6 ans il
sait se battre à l'espagnol est cuisant
il peut tirer un coup de pistolet sans
cligner des yeux à 14 ans escrime
française 16 ans et l'âge de la
formation du jugement et 22 horde
inculquer à son fils tous les principes
qui plus tard détermineront sa conduite
il leur arrive fréquemment d'utiliser le
soir à la veillée la lecture d'anecdotes
diverses contenu dans un mystérieux gros
volumes qu'ils conservent enfermé dans
un coffre
bertille havre a fait don je vous prie
la lecture de cette anecdote monfils
écoutez bien il y avait une fois dans
une ville d'italie appelé ravenne un
jeune homme nommé tribu
ils étaient beaux riches et remplis
d'une haute opinion de lui même jeune
fille de ravenne se mettait aux fenêtres
pour le voir passer mais s'il prenait
quelques fois un peu de goût pour l'une
ou pour l'autre ils ne le lui témoignait
pas de peur de lui faire trop d'honneur
enfin nous c'est un orgueil ne plus
tenir contre le charme de la jeune et
belle nina des tiers à six bris bulls
dénia lui témoigner son amour nina
répondit que le seigneur tribuil celui
faisait bien de l'honneur mais que
depuis son enfance elle aimait son
cousin paix baldo djeddah ci est que
sûrement elle n'aimerait jamais que lui
à cette réponse inattendue prévu le
sortit en tenant les marques de la plus
extrême fureur le dimanche suivant
il aperçoit les deux amants à l'église
le prêtre monta enchères est dit mes
frères je suis ici pour publier les bans
de tebaldo et de nina bédiala c'est
quelqu'un fait-il opposition à leur
mariage
s'il fait l'opposition s'écrit tribunes
et en même temps il donne un coup de
poignard aux deux amants calmez-vous
monfils apprenez à écouter en silence et
sans montrer aucune réaction ont voulu
arrêter tribune
mais il tenait encore des coups de
poignard sortie de l'église puis de la
ville et gagne à l'état de venise
révulse et est orgueilleux gâté par la
fortune mais son âme était sensible les
remords vengèrent ses victimes il obtint
du sacristain de venir prier sur le
tombeau des deux fiancés autant de fois
qu'ils le désiraient un soir prévu ce
sens dormi près du tombeau et lorsqu'il
se réveilla il trouva que l'église est
fermée
il prit des aimants le parti d'y passer
la nuit
car il aimait entretenir sa tristesse
minuit sonne a alors la porte de la
sacristie s'ouvrit et tribuil ce qui est
entré le sacristain donnant sa lanterne
dans une main et un balai dans l'autre
et sacristain n'était qu'un squelette il
sonne à une petite cloche alors les
tombeaux s'ouvrir
les morts ils parurent enveloppé dans
leurs linceuls et entonnèrent des
litanies sur un ton fort mélancolique
salma dire ainsi pendant quelque temps
puis un mort
revêtu d'un surplis et d'une étole monta
sur la chaire ai dit mon père je suis
ici pour célébrer les bandes de
thévalles d'eau et de nina djerassi tam
et ribul si faites-vous opposition
envisage france à la place de tri luxe
ont évolué peur on ses pairs il me
semble que je règle hopper déshonorant
quelque façon le régiment des gardes aux
valeurs j'avais l'intention de te faire
rentrer
monseigneur si j'ose à dire mon avis à
votre excellence ce soit de prouver à
monsieur votre fils qu'il n'y a point de
revenants et le spectre et de mort qui
chante des litanies et qu'il ne peut y
en avoir
de cette manière là il n'aurait sûrement
pas peur monsieur y avons nous oublié
que je vous ai montré hier une histoires
de revenants écrite de la propre maman
bisaïeul monseigneur je ne donne pas mon
démenti au bisaïeul votre excellence
qu'est ce que vous appelez je ne donne
pas monde aimante et savez vous que
cette expression suppose la possibilité
d'en démenti donné par vous hamon
bisaïeul monseigneur je sais bien que je
suis trop peu de choses pour que
monseigneur votre bisaïeul voulu tirer
aucune réparation de moi hier que le
ciel vous préserve de faire des excuses
car elle supposerait une enfance
monseigneur il ne me reste plus qu'à me
soumettre au châtiment qu'il plaira à
votre excellence de m'infliger au nom de
son bisaïeul seulement pour l'honneur de
ma profession
j'aimerais que cette peine mais fut
administrée par votre grenier pour que
je puisse la considérer comme pénitence
ecclésiastiques
cette idée n'est point mauvaise
laissez-moi y réfléchir je vous donnerai
ma réponse demain
quant à vous mon fils j'accepte de vous
donner une dernière chance la chance
d'avoir l'honneur de redevenir monfils
écoutez donc attentivement l'histoire
comme à nous lire dans inigo
dans une ville d'italie appelé fait rare
il y avait un jeune homme à plélan d'ulf
c'était un libertin sans religion ce
n'est chant aimais passionnément le
commerce des courtisanes et il avait
fait le tour de toutes celles de la
ville mais aucune ne lui plutôt tant que
blanc de kader aussi parce qu'elles sont
passées toutes les autres en impuretés
blank a été non seulement libertines
intéressé dépravés mais elle voulait que
ses amants fils pour elle des actions
qu'ils aient déshonorait et elle
exigeait de l'enduit lf qui la conduisit
tous les soirs chez lui et la fille
souper avec sa mère et sa soeur
en apprenant cette demande
la bonne mère fondu en larmes et conjure
à son fils de voirie gare la réputation
de sa soeur landes ulf fit la sourde
oreille
blanquart redoubla d'insolence en voyant
la bonté des deux femmes est un des
propos très libre enfin leur signifier à
tout 2 qu'elle ferait bien de s'en aller
parce qu'elle voulait rester seul avec
l'enduro comprenant ce qui allait se
passer
les deux femmes furent presque soulagé
de s'en aller le lendemain la courtisane
raconte à cette histoire dans toute la
ville et pendant plusieurs jours on ne
parlera pas d'autre chose
si bien que le bruit public en un format
bientôt au douar de zambie frère de la
mère de l'andouille il poignarde à le
même jour
l'infâme blanka landes ulf couru chez sa
mère avec l'intention de l'accabler d'
outrage la pauvre mère était avec sa
fille est allé se mettre à table
lorsqu'elle vit entrer son fils et lui
demande ainsi blanka viendrait souper
puisse-t-elle venir des landes ulf et de
mener en enfer avec ton frère et toute
la famille des en pis oh mon dieu pardon
et lui dit la pauvre mère en tombant à
genoux
en ce moment la porte s'ouvrit avec
fracas il envie d'entrer un spectre have
inondé de 110 sur et deux coups de
poignard et conservant néanmoins avec
blanca une affreuse ressemblance la mère
et la soeur de landes ils se mirent en
prière et dieu leur fille la grâce de
pouvoir supporter ce spectacle sont
expirés d'horreur le fantôme s'avançait
a pas là et ça ici à table comme pour
souper
une horrible langue rouge lui pendaient
dehors de la bouche qu'il ouvrit si
grande que sa tête paru se partageront 2
il en sortit une flamme rougeâtre
ensuite ils avancent à une main tout
brûler prix d'un morceau de pain lavalas
et on entendit tomber sous la table tous
les morceaux dont berthe aussi sous la
table et lorsque le plat fut vide
le fantôme tic sans lendemain avec des
yeux épouvantable lui dit landes ulf
quand je soupe ici j couche allons mais
toi ou lis mon fils alphonse à la place
de l'an du fort il ya vous eu peur
mon cher père je vous assure que je
n'aurais pas eu la plus légère frayeur
quelques années plus tard van beurden
aborde avec son fils devenu un homme
le problème des femmes en d'infini et
passionnante causerie y la forme aussi
son fils de toutes les connaissances
philosophiques métaphysiques et autres
qu'il connaît n'oubliez pas mon fils que
s'il existe l'arrêt venant et les démons
sévices de minuit en chant du coq
[Musique]
on
mon père qui est cette merveilleuse
apparition une princesse au moins mais
qui mutilent aces monfils
n'oubliez jamais non plus que le démon
pour ce vouloir tentateur prend souvent
la forme la plus désirable pour un homme
celle d'une jolie femme vous voulez dire
non dans ce cas particulier je puis vous
affirmer qu'il s'agit non pas d'un démon
mais tout simplement d'une amie de votre
mère
comment s'appelle-t-elle si votre mail
et moi même avions voulu que vous
sachiez son nom nous vous l'aurions
présentez vous êtes donc à la fois bien
naïf et bien impertinent de poser cette
question je n'y répondrai pas et votre
mère non plus et puisque les femmes
semblent vous impressionner à ce point
une femme
ou une femme si vous voulez sachez
néanmoins pour votre gouverne que la
plus grande qualité d'un homme auprès
d'une femme c'est sa discrétion et
femmes sont bavardes elle aime à se
compter leurs aventures les et
n'admettent pas ce trait chez les hommes
auxquels ils ont accordé leur faveur et
si un homme contredit cette règle elles
le savent tout très vite et il voit
aussitôt diminuer ses bonnes fortunes
partout je m'en souviendrai mon père
avant votre mariage toulouse est permis
jouissez donc de la violence qu'elle
vous apporte
si la femme est vrai et s'il est en a
envoyé du démon ne tombez pas dans le
piège examinait bien son corps si vous
êtes appelés à voyager par le monde
certains accoutrements certaines coiffe
you qui nous sont inconnus peuvent
masquer les corn du démon ou ses pieds
fourchus n'ayez jamais peur chaque
événement contient son explication
même si nous sommes incapables de la
deviner ou de la comprendre
ayez recours à la croix les tentateurs
primaire s'effaceront mais certaines
autres créatures démoniaques succube
rang quitté astrologique sont beaucoup
plus subtil seuls retraités votre
sang-froid victor votre conduite
mon fils je n'ai plus grand chose à vous
apprendre je vous ai communiqué presque
tout ce que je sais regardez toujours
autour de vous et écoutez
chose chaque événement chaque être
vivant vous apportera du plaisir
l'expérience des connaissances nouvelles
chaque chose même désagréables à
première vue est utile en soit dans
l'éducation a tenté en premier lieu de
vous apprendre à vaincre la peur la peur
engendre toujours des désordres
regrettable un homme qui vingt sapeurs
et panneaux de contrôle et il a la
possibilité de réfléchir donc de prendre
en main toute situation
quelle qu'elle soit
[Musique]
mon fils aujourd'hui est un grand jour
votre éducation s'arrête là pour te
destiner désormais entre vos mains
g 100 g pour vous à l'honneur de vous
faire entrer au régiment des gars de
malone et j'ai obtenu une commission de
capitaine que moi si vous partez sur le
champ et j'ai donné des ordres
il est temps que je vous confie en
secret que je tiens de mon père et que
vous confierez à votre fils lorsque
voulant croire et digne
mon père s'il s'agit d'un trésor caché
je n'ai jamais regardé l'heure vous le
savez que comme un moyen pour venir au
secours des malheureux mont gerald
france il ne s'agit ici ni dormi
d'argent je vais vous montrer une botte
secrète avec laquelle en parant aux
contres et en marquant la flore konan
vous êtes sûr de désarmer votre ennemi
venez avec moi l'art mairie
[Musique]
ciao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monfils n'oubliez pas que le premier
bien d'un gentilhomme et son épée le
deuxième sa foi et le troisième sa
parole donnée monfils n'oubliez pas que
dieu dans sa clémence vous fera
peut-être subir man's épreuves physiques
et morales vous devez supporter les
premières et déjouer les seconds dans
l'éducation a tenté de vous armer pour
ces épreuves je souhaite que dieu vous
éprouve pour que vous puissiez prouver
votre courage votre netteté votre foi je
souhaite que le diable sa tata vous car
le diable s'attaque aux êtres les plus
pures j'ai fait mes preuves fait les
vôtres vous irez par mer et entrerait en
espagne par cadix je vous donne mes
domestique lopez et mosquito il vous
suivront partout je vous donne mon fils
ma bénédiction
[Musique]
il vous faudra aussi savoir trouver mais
parmi toutes les femmes celle qui sera
digne d'eux pendant votre corps la place
de votre mère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais bon
allez
je
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
oh
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien
ouais
[Musique]
mon jeune seigneur rieumes indiquer la
route à prendre pour aller madrid
je viens à 3 mais il faut prendre celle
de jaén par là où celle de l'estrémadure
par là et la troisième pourquoi ne pas
la prendre mon jeune seigneur le même
les archers de la saint germain âmes
dont vous connaissez la réputation et la
bravoure refuse de se charger d'aucune
expédition dans la sierra morena et 7
syrah est habité par quelques bandits ou
bohemian qui mangent les voyageurs
qu'ils assassinent mais ce n'est pas
tout les quelques rares rescapés sont
revenus avec les yeux crevés ou les
membres déchiquetés et tous attestent
par saint jacques de compostelle que le
voyageurs se rendant dans cette contrée
sauvage est assailli par mille terreur
capable de glace et les courages les
plus hardis des voix lamentable ce mail
tout bruit des torrents des mains
trompeuse l'égard des mains invisibles
le pousse vers des abîmes sans fond ceux
qui ont pu atteindre sains et saufs le
torrent du quad qui virent ne peuvent
résister au tournant la montagne des
trois frères trois brigands dont la
photo a disparu
les deux autres ont été pris et pendu à
une potence en haut de la montagne
le record animé par les démos se détache
la nuit et quitte le jb pour aller
tourner hanter les vivants
d'autres disent que ces deux hommes
furent condamnés à tort à la potence et
depuis il en de leur vengeance les
chemins de la sierra morena des travaux
de la cades est la plus courte celle de
la sierra morena
c'est donc celle que nous prendrons je
mange le seigneur mon jeu le seigneur je
vous conjure de choisir l'une de celles
qu embrase les voyageurs
ce choix peut convenir à des voyageurs
ordinaires mais le roi et en tue la
grâce de monneraye d'une commission de
capitaine au guardian les lois sacrées
de la norme et prescrivent de me rendre
à madrid par le plus court chemin sans
demander s'il est le plus dangereux
non je ne sais mieux alors votre grâce
me permettra de lui dire que si le roi
l'a honoré d'une compagnie aux gardes
avant d'en avoir l'âge il serait
expédient de faire des preuve de
prudence jeudi que lorsque les nemo
s'empare d'un pays achète la malchance
dans sa chambre sous les toits régressé
à l'heure du déjeuner nous trouverons de
lot de nombre à la salle cravey
mangeront une provision puis nous
coucherons la vente taxi banat demain
matin nocifs euros de nouvelles
provisions et nous serons prêts à
affronter le passage de montagne vous
voyez bien qu'on avait rien d'alarmant
et voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lopez occupants du dîner mosquito
s'occupera des chevaux m
m
[Musique]
regardez pas ce qu'il veut a disparu et
son cheval aussi
[Musique]
alors magistrat d'horreur nul avec la
ville se sont sûrement le démon qui ont
emporté mosquito alors pourquoi ne me
suis-je pas rapporter avant elle renie
monde et la trémie d'un mois à compter
ses prédicateurs et au rock de notre
famille il est le frère de la même chair
du beau-fils du beau père de ma
belle-mère et se trouve ainsi le plus
proche parent que nous ayons rien ne se
fait dans notre maison que par ses avis
un n'ai pas voulu les suivre et je m'en
trouve justement punis
il m'avait bien dit et les officiers aux
gars de wallonne te taper un rhétiques
avec leurs cheveux blonds leurs yeux
bleus leurs joues rouges
on dirait que les vieux chrétiens sens
de la couleur de notre dame date hotg.de
par saint luc et toi pertinent bavard
regarde ce que j'ai trouvé il reste
quatre filles
je prends mon fusil tu vas rester garder
les chevaux je vais essayer de découvrir
mosquito du mois sa trace dans tout le
sahel me laisser passer alors lui aussi
plein de dangers
bon je reste à garder les chevaux tu vas
voir si mosquito derrière cette colline
non je préfère acheter ici
boston
votre iphone
[Applaudissements]
bof bof bof tu t'en
lopez mascitto
[Musique]
là
nous
[Musique]
à
abl
nous
e
[Musique]
le serbe est instable
[Applaudissements]
thain de trois frères
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
oh
bon
[Musique]
on
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]